франсуа фійон інших теледебатах
виступаючи за перехід сантейних видів носа
над москвою через скільки днів вин
победа я на праймеріз конкурента дупи
і тпр 60 і дворічна екс-прем'єр моя
шанс промах ти на президентських виборах
лічильнику цю де париж зближення з
путіним досвіду не дай чогось або експерти 5
ч фійон моя біляш проросійські погляди
не шинний президент олланд на це їм
націю і дружно 100 сумкою що
під'їжджаєте інше путіна з частиною їхньої сили
його прем'єрства за крима 15 днів з вуст
вирішую відразу додому ліся про купили у
росіянам та місталію фійон у 2008-му
роті був у ставок та надання Україні та
грузії плану дій рік членства в
нато
полі так однозначно на судини в анексію
крима і петр i move резолюції
підняти від русі та економічних санкцій
у цьому французький політолог і народити на
перо і тінь біля води проросійських фійону
отже вибір чарів риторика і реально
політика
купити сумку відрі знята муся то я так
вин русу філ а ось ціни означає що win
pro путінський фійон рубав і критий не
заявлена ​​адреса Росії
у разив броня фійону президентом йому
вірність та зняття санкцій проти росії
то ви знання парижем криму гідну
росії
експерти прогнозу вати наберуться кажуть
що франція буде 1 цим носу пара чити
загальна європейські позиції та губи на
мою думку буде свій рідний повернення
до традиційної дипломатії ще до Росії
у на премку за менше не протистояння
а в псж ключове значення матами позиція
берліна більше теж багатого буду
закладіть вигляд то краще зал та шиття
конфорку та мер коли за піцу до ми виборі
у вас інші 2017 і я квд собі новий
президент США трамп 54 можна вас не сам
фійон його головну конкурентку і буду
право радикально марин ле пен яко
поважають одним знай loyal нижчих до
кремлі політики в західній Європі